le Führer Adolf Hitler est mort
des militants sans scrupules loin
derrière le front ont tenté de profiter
de la situation pour poignarder dans le
dos ceux qui se battent durement en
première ligne et prendre le pouvoir des
fins personnels
en cette heure de grand danger le
gouvernement du Reich a déclaré l'état
d'urgence militaire pour le maintien de
l'ordre et au même moment m'a remis le
pouvoir exécutif ainsi que le haut
commandement de la Wehrmacht
c'est à ce titre que je transmets les
ordres suivants
je transfère le pouvoir exécutif au sein
de la zone de guerre au commandement de
l'armée de réserve que je nomme
également commandant suprême des forces
combattantes sur le territoire
malheureusement cette annonce n'a jamais
été transmise et n'est pas non plus
issue d'une imagination fertile
il s'agit en substance des ordres de
l'opération Valkyrie qui devait être
transmis à tous les commandants d'unités
dans le cas où le régime devrait faire
face à un soulèvement
par exemple la révolte des 12 millions
d'ouvriers esclaves exploités par
l'Allemagne
enfermé dans des camps de travail
travaillant jusqu'à l'épuisement et
vivant dans la famille
à l'origine ils étaient composés de ceux
que les nazis traitaient avec mépris
homosexuels juif gitan et sans abri
une fois la guerre déclarée leur nombre
fut dilué dans la masse de civils venue
des pays conquis dans l'Est de l'Europe
il n'était pas les seuls à être
considérés comme une menace par le
Troisième Reich
le haut commandement craignait que le
succès dévastateur des bombardements
alliés sur les villes allemandes ne
créent l'anarchie
ils craignait que ce flottement de
l'autorité ne soit exploitée par
l'opposition pour lancer un mouvement
révolutionnaire qui s'attaquerait au
Reich un mouvement qui serait manipulé
par des traîtres nazis ou encore par des
officiers renégats de la Wehrmacht en
quête de pouvoir et dont l'objectif
serait de se débarrasser d'Hitler et de
remplacer son gouvernement
le Führer avait conscience que le nombre
des pertes allemandes augmentant les
menaces dont il faisait l'objet
augmentaient également à tel point qu'il
était fier de sa tactique qui consistait
à changer sans cesse son programme
d'activité ou à écourter ses visites
officielles sans préavis
déjà il évitait de se rendre à Berlin
préférence retirer dans son fief
romantique des Alpes bavaroises à
bercheuse Gaden ou encore dans son
bunker fortifié et sécurisé en forêt en
plus orientale Adolphe le repaire du
loup
Hitler adorait faire référence au loup
en baptisant ces lieux de retraite
faisant le rapprochement avec son prénom
Adolf qui en vieille allemand désignait
le loup
à présent qu'il était lui-même plus loup
solitaire qu'à n'importe quel autre
moment de son ascension politique il
n'avait pas été difficile de lui faire
approuver l'opération Valkyrie
le chef suprême du Reich de plus en plus
paranoïaque ne pouvait qu'être intéressé
par un plan prêt à être mis en œuvre en
cas de rébellion surtout que ce plan lui
était présenté par l'homme à la tête de
l'adverbe le renseignement militaire
allemand l'amiral Canaris
ce que Hitler ignorait c'est que Canaris
n'avait plus confiance en lui depuis
1938 et que maintenant il travaillait
activement contre lui le plan qu'il
venait d'approuver sous couvert de
contrer la rébellion naissante devait en
fait fournir la structure à une
conspiration destinée à l'éliminer lui
Hitler
Canaris allait mettre en place tout un
mécanisme permettant un transfert direct
du pouvoir une fois Hitler assassinée et
pour que ce projet réussisse il ne
devait pas y avoir de flottement ou de
vide au centre à Berlin
la plus grande force militaire à Berlin
était la réserve de l'armée dont la
fonction était de fournir des personnels
pour l'entraînement et pour remplacer
les soldats tués au front
l'homme qui tenait cette position clé
était le général Friedrich from et
c'était lui qui en normal devait lancer
l'opération Valkyrie et en faire
l'annonce
même si les conspirateurs étaient
certains qu'il se rallierait à leur plan
en cas d'hésitation il serait
immédiatement arrêté et un autre général
prendrait sa place
bien que l'opération Valkyrie était
approuvée en 1943 au printemps 1944 rien
n'avait été fait pour la mettre en œuvre
puis en juin de la même année la
résistance bénéficia d'un énorme coup de
chance
l'un des siens un officier séduisant
intelligent et habile klauschengraphe
funsta offenberg fut nommé chef
d'état-major du général from ce qui lui
donna non seulement le pouvoir de donner
des ordres au nom de from mais également
la possibilité de rencontrer
régulièrement Hitler
les Valkyries étaient des femmes
guerrières et les et armées dans la
mythologie nordique et dont le rôle
était de collecter les armes des plus
courageux soldats tombés au combat puis
de les escorter au valhallas le royaume
des dieux maintenant il semblait qu'une
Valkyrie était sur le point de voler
encore une fois et l'âme qu'elle devait
convoyer n'était autre que celle du
Führer Adolf Hitler
les résistants à Hitler ni par les
raisons qui les opposaient au fureur ni
par les objectifs qu'ils poursuivent
les complots se forgèrent tout au long
d'une période qui commença avec les
tensions découlant de la politique
militaire agressive d'Hitler précédant
la Seconde Guerre mondiale et qui
s'acheva avec l'échec de l'opération
Walkyrie lorsque le Reich se débarrassa
férocement de tous ces opposants
potentiels
la plupart des conjurés faisaient partie
de l'armée les raisons en été multiples
l'armée se sentait menacée par ce
caporal de la Première Guerre mondiale
qui avait pris le pouvoir et encourager
le développement des ssimler en
concurrence avec l'armée régulière
le corps des officiers de la Wehrmacht
était très aristocratique et n'avait que
peu de sympathie pour une philosophie
qui remettait en cause les prérogatives
de l'ancien système plus encore les
officiers qui servaient sur la ligne de
front ne pouvait fermer les yeux sur les
barbaries qui étaient commises
quotidiennement en leur présence et
enfin l'armée avait les armes
mais il y avait d'autres opposants
politiques et religieux de toutes
origines sociales
l'armée elle-même était constituée
d'individus très différents décidés à
agir pour des raisons tout aussi variées
certains adhéraient aux ambitions du
Führer mais craignaient que sa stratégie
ne mène l'Allemagne au désastre
d'autres lui étaient opposés depuis le
départ pour des raisons morales ou
politiques tandis que d'autres se
soulevèrent et pour certains le plus
fermement en raison de leur appartenance
au parti nazi quand il montra son vrai
visage
certains souhaitaient simplement arrêter
Hitler et l'amener devant les tribunaux
politiquement ils étaient de tous les
bords des monarchistes de droite aux
chrétiens socialistes de gauche
parmi eux les légalistes qui pensaient
non seulement quittent l'air avaient
droit à un procès loyal mais aussi que
ce procès devait être rendu public pour
eux ce n'était pas seulement de justice
dont il était question il fallait aussi
être en mesure de démontrer plus tard
que la conspiration n'avait fait agir
pour le bien de la patrie
des rumeurs de complot avait vu le jour
juste après la Grande Guerre et avait
fleuri pendant l'ascension d'Hitler et
la persécution des juifs qui furent
pointés du doigt comme étant les grands
traîtres ainsi que pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale elle-même
il y avait également de ferdans
religieux qui de manière presque comique
en plein milieu d'un tel carnage jugeait
que tuer des innocents était mal
mais pour la majeure partie de la
résistance Hitler devait être assassiné
au fur et à mesure que la guerre
progressait la balance pesait de plus en
plus lourdement du côté de l'assassinat
Adolf Hitler avait fini par renoncer au
coup d'État pour accéder au pouvoir
après avoir tenté sa chance et échouer
il avait été nommé Chancelier en 1933 et
aux élections du 6 mars la même année le
NSDAP le parti nazi avait remporté 43,9%
des suffrages devenant ainsi le plus
grand parti du Reichstag le parlement
allemand
17 jours après son élection il avait
manipulé les autres parties à
l'exception notable du Parti socialiste
en faisant voter la loi des pleins
pouvoirs
la pierre angulaire de toutes démocratie
reste la séparation de l'exécutif et du
législatif avec le pouvoir du Parlement
d'approuver ou désapprouver toute loi
laissant à l'exécutif le soin de
l'amener à bien
la loi des pleins pouvoirs annulaient
cette séparation plaçant le pouvoir
législatif entre les mains d'Hitler
le Parti socialiste fut immédiatement
déclaré illégal et le 14 juillet les
autres partis réalisèrent qu'il s'était
eux-mêmes mis en dehors du système
le cabinet d'Hitler déclara le parti
nazi le seul parti légal en Allemagne
le second acte d'Hitler visait
directement un groupe qui avait été
pourtant l'instrument de son ascension
au pouvoir les SA ou je tourmarbe appelé
aussi les chemises brunes en raison de
leur uniforme
formé en 1920 pour protéger le parti
nazi contre les attaques physiques de
ses opposants politiques cette troupe
spécialisée dans le combat de rue avec
grossi jusqu'à compter 2 millions 900
000 hommes et son chef Rome un vieil
allié d'Hitler visait le poste de
ministre de la défense avec l'intention
d'incorporer les sa dans l'armée
mais l'armée avait été réduite à moins
de 100.000 hommes suite au traité de
Versailles et elle risquait dans ce cas
d'être absorbé par les sa réaction était
facile à prévoir
ancien général héros de la Grande Guerre
et président du Reich menaçait d'imposer
la loi martiale
plus encore la lutte contre la
délinquance de rue menée par les sa
n'était plus utile et la taille
imposante du corps de troupe menaçaient
le parti nazi lui-même
en juin 1934 hitlera
à ses côtés Himmler le chef des SS
rivaux des shoot Staffel ou section de
protection avec constitué de toutes
pièces un dossier démontrant que Rome
touchait des pots de vin français pour
renverser Hitler
l'exécution des leaders des sa fut
ordonnés et pris la forme de l'opération
connu sous le nom de nuit des longs
couteaux nuit durant laquelle fur
massacré non seulement les chefs DSA
mais également un grand nombre
d'opposants au régime d'Hitler
les dessinateurs de la presse
internationale s'empressèrent de
dénoncer dans leur dessin la sauvagerie
de l'événement mais cela ne faisait pas
rire un homme énigme prescov
issu de l'élite militaire prussienne et
partageant l'hostilité du parti nazi
vis-à-vis du traité de Versailles il
avait été choqué de la brutalité de
l'opération et allait devenir un
conspirateur invétéré contre Hitler
jouissant d'une réputation considérable
récompensée de la Croix de Fer de
première classe lors de la bataille de
la Marne son officier supérieur lui
avait dit vous deviendrez chef de
l'état-major général où vous mourrez sur
l'échafaud
quoi qu'il en soit pour le moment Hitler
avait sauvé l'arme et Hindenburg lui
adressa une lettre lui exprimant sa plus
profonde gratitude
il donne Bourgue mourut en août le
cabinet déclara la présidence dormante
et transféra tous ses pouvoirs aux
chancelier Hitler
en 1936 au nom du Reich Hitler entra en
rhénani le territoire frontalié avec la
Belgique qui avait été occupé par les
Alliés en vertu du traité de Versailles
30 000 soldats allemands y entèrent sans
rencontrer de résistance de l'armée
française
les Français eurent pas le courage
politique de s'opposer au tyran car il
craignait de ne pas avoir le soutien des
Britanniques
la Rhénanie fut concédé sans effusion de
sang
le public allemand était enchanté et la
popularité d'Hitler grimpa en flèche
la prochaine étape en 1937 était
d'annexer l'Autriche par la force si
nécessaire
cela l'opposa immédiatement à son chef
d'état-major le général Ludwig
officiant ambitieux mais avec une vision
limitée mec se trompa à plusieurs
reprises lors de ses controverses avec
Hitler
ce n'était pas sur des conditions
morales qu'il s'opposaient ni sur aucun
des objectifs d'Hitler c'était surtout
un problème de timing
chargé de donner les ordres pour
organiser le plan d'union avec
l'Autriche il commença par refuser
n'acceptant ensuite uniquement que parce
qu'Hitler l'avait convaincu que
landschluzz l'union politique avec
l'Autriche ne déboucherait pas sur une
guerre
l’autriche la terre natale d'Hitler que
celui-ci voulait envahir pour l'unir à
l'Allemagne avait spontanément accepté
sa proposition de ralliement
à ce moment la dictature d'Hitler était
devenue absolue
il avait renvoyé le ministre de la
guerre post précédemment connu sous le
nom de ministre de la Défense le
remplaçant par l'un des siens le général
kitele et changeant le nom du poste
encore une fois pour aubert-commando
derbermacht ou ok
il s'était réservé pour lui-même le
poste de chef suprême des armées
en privant en réalité l'armée de son
pouvoir d'influence sur la nomination du
ministre de la guerre Hitler s'est fait
un grand nombre d'ennemis dans les rangs
des officiers
le précédent ministre de la guerre et le
chef suprême des forces armées avait été
forcée de démissionner dans ce qui est
connu sous le nom d'affaires Bloomberg
Hirsch Bloomberg un maréchal sexagénaire
c'était marié avec une secrétaire de 26
ans
Hermann Goering étant son témoin de
mariage
la preuve que l'épouse de Bloomberg
avait été une prostituée 20 aux mains de
la Gestapo d'himler
Goering et Himmler présentèrent le
rapport de police à Hitler et Bloomberg
proposa de démissionner ironiquement ses
tablumberg que Hitler devait le fait que
l'armée continuait de lui offrir son
soutien au-delà de toutes ses espérances
c'est lui qui avait changé le serment
des officiers qui devait dorénavant juré
loyauté non pas au pays mais au fureur
lui-même ce serment obligea de nombreux
officiers à se taire au moment où il
leur aurait fallu s'opposer à Hitler
peu après le commandant en chef des
forces armées Werner van triche fut
accusé par guring et Himmler de pratique
homosexuelles indigné par l'accusation
il démissionna bien qu'il fut ensuite
réhabilitée par une cour d'honneur
présidée par Goering
les deux hommes Bloomberg et from Frisch
avaient beaucoup critiqué
l'expansionnisme d'Hitler c'est affaire
éloignable encore plus du Führer
beaucoup d'officiers dont deux en
particulier énigme prescov et l'homme
qui allait devenir son chef hiérarchique
Gunther voncloud
en ce qui concerne la politique
expansionniste du Reich en 1938 bec le
chef de l'état-major général n’était pas
opposé au plan du Führer d'annexer la
Tchécoslovaquie
mais il pensait à la différence du chef
suprême que la France honorerait ses
accords de défense avec la
Tchécoslovaquie et qu'elle serait
soutenue par la Grande-Bretagne
à son avis labermacht n'était pas assez
forte pour affronter ces deux armées en
particulier si elle mettait leur force
en commun
la conséquence selon Beck d'une telle
invasion serait la guerre et la
destruction de l'Allemagne mais à
présent avec le pouvoir et la popularité
dont jouissait le Führer aucun de ses
généraux n'osaient plus s'opposé à celui
que Beck surnommait en privé le petit
soldat de première classe mégalomane
en désespoir de cause becphe pour une
démission massive de tous les officiers
supérieurs des forces armées
il devint le chef de fil du mouvement
contre la guerre et future heureux de
trouver un allié inattendu en la
personne de l'amiral vilaine Canaris le
chef du renseignement militaire
Canaris descendait d'une famille
d'industriels aisée de Westphalie il
avait servi comme commandant de
sous-marin et avait été crédité de 17
bâtiments coulés lors de la première
guerre mondiale
bien qu'il n'ait jamais été membre du
parti nazi il avait fait partie des
fameux fright cors après la Grande
Guerre et estimé quitter était l'un des
seuls moyens de sauver l'Allemagne du
Parti communiste
mais au moment où il s'allie à bec il
était arrivé à la conclusion que le
Führer ne faisait que mener l'Allemagne
à sa perte par une voie différente du
Parti communiste
à l'insu du chef de l'état-major général
il avait pris part avant l'annexion de
la Tchécoslovaquie à un complot en vue
d'éliminer Hitler et l'ensemble du parti
nazi
incapable d'arriver à un accord avec ses
pairs pour une démission en masse bec
réussit tout de même à les convaincre
que si Hitler faisait un pas décisif
vers la guerre il faudrait l'éliminer
c'est à ce moment que le gouvernement
britannique décida d'intervenir
bien qu'ils aient été avertis des plans
du général par un intermédiaire il
décidèrent qu'il ne pouvait pas lui
faire confiance d'autant qu'ils
éprouvaient une considération presque
superstitieuse envers les capacités
d'Adolf Hitler
il doutait également du niveau de
préparation de l'abrity charmille et de
sa capacité à affronter l'Allemagne un
effet miroir absurde des doutes de bec
de retour de Munich le Premier ministre
britannique agita triomphe allemand un
papier qui l'annonça comme la paix de
notre époque
le gouvernement britannique avait
lâchement accepté l'invasion allemande
des Sudètes et en échange le Führer leur
avait assuré qu'il n'avait plus d'autres
ambitions territoriales
l'excuse encore une fois était que ce
territoire avait été injustement coupé
de l'Allemagne par le traité de
Versailles
la conspiration qui constituait la
première menace contre la dictature
avant l'opération Valkyrie et choix
dans un geste de défiance vis-à-vis
d'Hitler bec démissionna de son poste
acceptant en même temps une future
nomination pour prix de son silence
l'un des opposants clés d'Hitler
impliqués dans le complot de 1938
n'était pas un officier de l'armée Carl
guerre de l'air ancien maire de Leipzig
avait été considéré comme un chancelier
potentiel en 1932 juste avant
l'accession d'Hitler au pouvoir
sous le régime d'Hitler il fut l'un des
rares politiciens à avoir eu le courage
de braver le programme nazi en
particulier l'élimination des Juifs
malgré sa réélection en 1934 il
démissionna son poste ayant été
continuellement miné par l'adjoint au
maire un militant nazi
devenu directeur commercial exporte de
la firme de Robert Bosch il profita de
ses voyages pour faire part des
intentions du Troisième Reich aux
intéressés dont Winston Churchill et
pour rechercher un soutien au putsch de
bec
en même temps il tenta de faire accepter
par le gouvernement britannique 10000
Juifs qui étaient parqués à la frontière
polonaise
sur ces deux points il revint bredouille
malgré son accord avec Chamberlain le
chancelier allemand voulait faire
d'autres ajustements au traité de
Versailles
lors de l'accord de 1918 une grande
partie de la Prusse orientale avait été
cédée à la Pologne dont le corridor de
danciges Hitler était à présent près un
réclamer la restitution
bien que la Pologne eu déjà signé un
pacte de non-agression avec l'Allemagne
depuis 1934 un accord de défense anglo
polonais fut signé le 25 août 1939
alignant la position des Britanniques
sur celle des Français
c'était la veille même du jour prévu par
Hitler pour l'invasion de la Pologne et
il dû la retarder
une nouvelle fois les officiers
supérieurs de la Wehrmacht poussèrent un
soupir de soulagement avec girdler
préparant les conditions d'une paix qui
serait demandée à l'Angleterre et la
France pas un gouvernement post-itérien
les généraux avaient toujours le projet
de se débarrasser d'Hitler avec cette
fois pour signal déclencheur de leur
action une déclaration de guerre contre
les nations occidentales dont beaucoup
pensaient qu'elle mènerait à une guerre
mondiale
en dépit du gras d'élevé des officiers
impliqués dont le nouveau chef
d'état-major des armées Alder qui
succéda à bec le complot et choix
difficile de savoir ce qui claire
connaissait réellement de ses plans
l'amiral Canaris prévint les
conspirateurs que s'ils se réunissaient
à The Sun le quartier général de l'armée
il serait arrêté et le Führer lui-même
dit à Alder qu'il détruirait l'esprit de
The Sun ce que ce dernier prix comme un
avertissement clair
trompé par l'apparente volonté des
alliés de continuer les pourparler
l'armée allemande envahit la Pologne le
premier septembre et le 3 septembre 1939
la France et la Grande-Bretagne lui
déclara la guerre
un des personnages les plus importants à
entrer en résistance contre Hitler fut
Helmut graff funk dont les positions
antifascistes furent renforcés lors de
la campagne de Pologne
malgré ses antécédents militaires et
aristocratiques son arrière-grand-père
avait mené avec succès l'armée allemande
pendant les guerres austrocrusiennes et
franco-prussienne les opinions de moldka
tendaient vers le socialisme et vers une
pensée philanthropique
adepte du droit et des lois il refusa de
devenir juge car cela aurait fait de lui
un membre du parti nazi
il en a plutôt poursuivre ses études de
droit à Oxford
en 1939 il fut recruté dans la verre
sous les ordres de l'amiral Canaris et
fut choqué par ce qu'il vit quand
l'armée du Reich progressa à travers les
territoires occupés
plus d'un millier de personnes sont
assassinées chaque jour et un autre
milieu de jeunes Allemands s'habituent
au meurtre
lorsqu'il rentra chez lui le traitement
infligé aux Juifs le révulsa
les Juifs de Berlin sont raflées comment
peut-on être au courant et vaquer
tranquillement à ses occupations
bien qu'il n'est jamais été en faveur
d'un assassinat d'Hitler autant par
conviction religieuse que par crainte de
le voir devenir un martyr il transmis
des informations et offrites au
britanniques d'aller aussi loin que
possible pour soutenir leurs efforts
mais son offre fut ignorée
avec un grand nombre de personnes
partageant ses idées il créa un groupe
politique et philosophique connu sous le
nom de cercle chriso dont les sujets de
discussion incluaient le traitement à
réserver au criminels de guerre après la
chute du régime éclairien qu'il
considérait comme une électable
bien que par nature non activiste son
cercle restant en contact rapproché avec
beaucoup de conspirateurs et il dû
finalement partager leur sort
car la séparation entre activiste et non
activiste était parfois flou
Ulric graff funspering par exemple avait
un pied dans les deux camps
cet aristocrate chrétien passionné à la
fois officier et propriétaire terrien
fin non seulement partie du cercle
chriso mais participa également à
l'opération Valkyrie
les frères von staffenberg était
également membre du cercle
et tandis que le massacre commençait sur
le front Hitler tendait à prouver qu'il
Monette une vie paisible et heureuse
un sympathisant communiste du Würtenberg
qui avait travaillé durant un temps dans
une usine de montre avait également
observé avec inquiétude l'entrée en
guerre de l'Allemagne
les raisons de son opposition au régime
nazi et initialement son soutien au
mouvement des travailleurs elle est
ensuite se transformer en aversion pour
le traitement infligé au juifs et à la
crainte Hitler plonge l'Allemagne dans
un véritable enfer
il planifia soigneusement sa tentative
le 8 novembre 1938 il se rendit à Munich
pour participer à la commémoration du
putsch raté d'Hitler de 1923 celui où il
avait tenté de prendre par la force le
contrôle de l'État lors d'un
rassemblement politique au Burger
brawkeller la brasserie
après avoir remarqué que les mesures de
sécurité n'étaient pas adaptées il
revint l'année suivante et pendant un
mois restant caché pendant la nuit dans
la brasserie il parvint à creuser un
pilier à côté des haut-parleurs de la
tribune et à placer une bombe à
l'intérieur
malheureusement Hitler descendit du
podium plutôt que prévu pour prendre le
train pour Berlin
la bombe explosa après qu'il soit parti
tué en 8 personnes elles heures fut
capturé et torturé par la Gestapo avant
d'être envoyé au camp de concentration
deux AXA
avant la guerre l'Union soviétique avec
tenté de trouver un accord de défense
avec la France et l'Allemagne mais ces
efforts étaient restés vains
craignant que les alliés ne soutiennent
pas la Russie si elle était attaquée par
l'Allemagne Staline signa le 23 août un
pacte de non-agression d'une durée de 10
ans mettant ainsi l'Allemagne à l'abri
d'une attaque sur sa frontière orientale
lorsqu'elle envahit la Pologne
cet accord était renforcé d'un protocole
secret qui répartissait l'Europe de
l'Est en zone d'intérêt soviétique et
allemand
début octobre l'annexion de la Pologne
était terminée
la quatrième armée avait été dirigée par
Gunther voncloud un général qui se
révéla un stratège hors pair lors de
cette campagne et plus tard dans les
Ardennes la campagne qui fit capituler
la France
un lieutenant de 32 ans frunsta
offenberg nota avec une désapprobation
tout aristocratique le mélange au sein
de la population polonaise mais ce con
cela avec l'utilisation qui pouvait en
être faite dans une lettre écrite à sa
femme il commentait la population ici
est un incroyable mélange de Juifs et
d'autre peuples qui n'obéissent qu'au
fouet les milliers de prisonniers fait
ici seraient très utiles à notre
agriculture
mais en dépit de ces positions il était
loin d'éprouver de la sympathie pour le
mouvement nazi
il trouvait que la crystal Nacht
l’inflammante nuit de Cristal avait
déshonoré l'Allemagne
c'était cette nuit de novembre 1938 au
cours de laquelle plus de 200 synagogues
avaient brûlé des dizaines de milliers
de commerces Juifs avaient été pillés et
détruit plus de 25000 juifs déportés
dans des camps de concentration
remarqué par Gerg lors du rassemblement
de Munich cela l'avait conforté dans la
conviction quitter devait être tué
partager son opinion dont l'oncle de
funsta offenberg Nicolas graffone
hookschool il avait invité fansta
offenberg a rejoindre la résistance mais
ça demande avait échoué mais avant même
que l'invasion de la Pologne ne soit
terminée ce qui y vit le fit changer
d'avis
alors que les troupes britanniques
étaient déployées sur le continent lors
de la drôle de guerre durant laquelle
aucun camp n'attaquer l'autre l'ancien
maire de Leipzig guerre de l'air
approcha à nouveau Adler le chef
d'état-major des armées pour lui
demander de participer à un coup d'état
cette fois Adler
avait joué et gagné il ne fit pas de
rapport sur cette entrevue craignant
peut-être des représailles pour sa
participation à la précédente
conspiration
en 1940 Hitler lança avec succès des
attaques sur le Danemark et la Norvège
dans le but de sécuriser les réserves de
minerai de fer en Suède
en même temps les Soviétiques envahir
les pays baltes qu'ils occupèrent puis
déclarèrent la guerre à la Finlande et
réussir à obtenir des concessions
ces victoires face à une apparente
inertie engendrait rage et frustration
en Grande-Bretagne ou
neuville-chamberlin fut limogé et
remplacé par Winston Churchill
pour les comploteurs anti Hitler en
Allemagne cela constitue certainement
une bonne nouvelle l'opposition de
Churchill à Hitler depuis des années
étant de notoriété publique
après la capitulation de la France en
juin 1940 la Hongrie la Roumanie et la
Slovaquie demandèrent à adhérer à l'axe
et en novembre de la même année leur
requête fut acceptée elle rejoignèrent
le Führer pour sa prochaine grande
entreprise l'invasion de la Russie
connue sous le nom d'opération
Barbarossa
avec plus de 4 millions 500 000 soldats
qui devaient être massés près de la
frontière française Hitler était sur le
point d'ouvrir un deuxième front
cela semblait si fou que Staline refusa
d'entendre les avertissements de son
réseau d'espion
il était convaincu que les Allemands
achèveraient leur confrontation avec la
Grande-Bretagne avant de s'intéresser à
la Russie
il ne doutait pas qu'une attaque
surviendrait un jour pas seulement parce
que la philosophie fasciste était
directement opposée au communisme mais
aussi parce que le chef suprême de
l'Allemagne pensait que la Russie était
peuplée de slave une race d'esclaves à
peine supérieure aux Juifs
l'opération Barbarossa envisageait de
diviser les forces d'invasion allemande
en trois groupes le groupement Nord
qu'il devait pénétrer les États baltes
tenus par les Soviétiques et prendre
Lénine grade le groupement Sud dont la
mission était de foncer à travers
l'Ukraine pour se saisir des champs
pétrolifères du Caucase
et le plus important le groupement
centre dont le rôle sous l'autorité de
funbox était d'avancer sur Smolensk et
de prendre Moscou
lorsque funbock tomba malade en 1942 van
klugher lui succéda
tous deux étaient consternés par le fait
de devoir prendre Moscou avec une armée
scindée en trois et demandèrent en vain
à Hitler que les forces soient combinées
et lancées sur la capitale soviétique
ils furent indignés d'apprendre que
plutôt que de renforcer leur armée le
Führer avait décidé de retirer les
Panzer Division du groupement centre et
de les envoyer à Leningrad au nord et en
Ukraine au sud
funklug commença à douter de la santé
mentale d'Hitler
leur seul appui serait les Waffen SS qui
alliait un grand courage et un
engagement sans faille à une maîtrise
inégalée dans l'élimination et la
démoralisation des populations locales
dans ces circonstances folker future
heureux de rencontrer un extraordinaire
chef d'état-major le colonel Henning
phone PRESCO
le fait qu'il soit le neveu du
commandant du groupement centre phonebok
ne pouvait que favoriser l'avancement de
l'homme qu'elle est devenir le principal
recruteur de l'opération Valkyrie et
l'instigateur de nombreux complots
le 22 juin 1941 plus de 4 millions de
soldats de l'axe entrèrent en action le
groupement centre composé principalement
des deuxième et troisième Panzer Groupon
et des quatrième et neuvième armée FIFA
à quatre cordes armée soviétiques qui
occupaient une vaste saillie s'étend
dans loin dans le territoire polonais
alors que les Panzer Gruppen perçaient
aux jonctions des cordes armées
l'infanterie donna l'assaut sur la
saillie submergeant les troupes
soviétiques
une défaite cuisante fut infligée à
l'Armée rouge
mais à présent la Wehrmacht n'avançait
plus attendant les ordres de Berlin ce
qui donna le temps aux Russes de se
regrouper
une contre-atta Cruz fut lancée le 6
juillet mais fut prise en étau par les
deuxièmes et 3e panzergroupen qui firent
plus de 180 000 prisonniers
malgré la raréfaction des
ravitaillements les généraux prenaient
une marche sur Moscou
mais Hitler envoya les Panzer au Nord et
au Sud
avec la chute de Kiev au sud et plus de
300 000 prisonniers supplémentaires
l'avancée sur Moscou ne commence
encore une fois les Soviétiques
réussissaient à trouver des renforts en
nombre illimité juste au moment où le
temps commençait à se détériorer
épuisé et privé de ravitaillement
fan-claug était embourbé comme le fût
Napoléon avant lui
les premiers blizzards firent leur
apparition lorsque le quatrième
panzergrouper va finalement en aide au
groupement centre à moins de 24 km de
Moscou les angelures et les maladies
diminuelles efficacité et le 6 décembre
l'Armée rouge contre-attaqua reprenant
aux Allemands plus de 300 des kilomètres
qu'ils avaient si durement gagné
il fut difficile de semer les germes du
mécontentement dans l'esprit des
officiers supérieurs alors que des
victoires spectaculaires venaient d'être
remportées pendant l'été
malgré tout phonresco ne perdez pas
espoir et ses convictions furentes par
celles de l'aide de camp de fun block
Heinrich graff funendorf qui avait été
témoin de massacre de juifs lorsqu'il
servait en Biélorussie
en dépit du fait qu'il semblait n'avoir
aucune influence sur son oncle funbox
qui refusait de tolérer la moindre
attaque contre son chef
ventresco et son jeune confédéré avait
déjà prévu de kidnapper Hitler lorsqu'il
viendrait visiter le groupement centre à
la mi-haute
quoi qu'il en soit en raison des
précautions avec lesquelles toutes les
mesures de sécurité étaient maintenant
prises la voiture qu'ils avaient
l'intention d'utiliser pour le conduire
sur le front fut écarté au profit d'une
autre provenant de son parc personnel
dans le même temps les conspirateurs à
Berlin recentraient leurs espoirs sur le
maréchal Erwin le commandant en chef
Ouest dont le quartier général se
trouvait à Paris
ayant participé à l'origine un plan tiré
par les cheveux visant seulement à
convaincre les officiers supérieurs de
ne pas exécuter les ordres émanant
d'Hitler il les persuada finalement que
ce dernier devait être capturé et
renversé
un plan était prévu pour l'été suivant
au moment de la réactivation de la
campagne de Russie mais il dit
auparavant se rendre à l'hôpital pour
une opération des hémorroïdes et Hitler
décida de lui retirer son commandement
pendant son hospitalisation
funsta offenberg avait été rattaché au
commandement de la Wehrmacht loin du
front mais néanmoins à l'intérieur du
territoire soviétique
l'une de ces tâches consistait à tenter
de recruter de soi-disant volontaires
issus des unités de l'Armée rouge
capturées au combat et illus fréquemment
l’occasion de voir comment non seulement
les SS mais aussi la Wehrmacht traitait
les prisonniers russes
on estime que près d'un million furent
abattus de sang-froid
2800000 autres mourir tant huit mois en
1941 et 1942
il n'était pas prisonnier de guerre dans
le sens où on l'entend habituellement
c'est-à-dire membre des Forces armées
tous les hommes âgés de 15 à 65 ans
étaient capturés
après avoir marché des centaines de
kilomètres pour rejoindre les camps les
conditions de vie quand ils arrivaient
étaient atroces les camps étaient de
simples clôtures de barbelés il n'y
avait pas de baraquement et il survivait
comme il pouvait sans abri et avec trop
peu à manger dans le froid de l'hiver
russe
froid faisait un travail encore plus
efficace que les chambres à gaz dans les
camps de la mort chose qui avait
d'ailleurs été prévue par les
planificateurs militaires
à cela s'ajoutait les exécutions
disciplinaires mais la majorité des
prisonniers mouraient de faim
Goering plaisantait dans les camps de
prisonniers de guerre soviétique après
avoir mangé tout ce qu'il pouvait
jusqu'à la semelle de leur botte il
commençait à se manger entre eux et ce
qui est plus grave il mangeait même une
sentinelle allemande
ce fut dans ces conditions que fontsta
Hoffenberg rencontra le général von
PRESCO ainsi qu'une autre recrue
Fabienne Funchla brendorff et fut
rapidement acquis à leur cause à savoir
l'assassinat du chef suprême du Reich
comme beaucoup de conspirateurs
schlabrendorf aide de camp de fanfresco
avait suivi une formation d'avocat
il avait participé à plus d'une
tentative et agissait comme agent de
liaison entre phone Tresco et Berlin
notamment avec bec et guerre de l'Eure
staffenberg devait rester en Russie pour
la bataille de Stalingrad la plus
sanglante bataille de l'histoire du
monde
cette ville a 200 km au sud-ouest de
Moscou qui allait voir les plans du
Reich pour la domination de l'Europe
subir l'un de leurs plus gros revers
elle durera d'août 1942 à février 1943
plus de 51 000 russes avaient été
enrôlées dans les forces de l'Axe par
offenberg et ses collègues pour cette
bataille
les pertes furent gigantesques avec plus
d'un million 200000 hommes pour les
Soviétiques et 850 000 pour les troupes
de l'axe
mais Stalingrad avait tenu
des 91 000 Allemands fait prisonniers
seulement 5000 revivent un jour
l'Allemagne
en février 1943 je dois offenberg
demanda à reprendre du service actif et
obtint le poste d'officier des
opérations à la 10e Panzer Division à
Tunis
à propos de la présence allemande en
Afrique du Nord l'historien William a
Murray vie la décision de renforcer
l'Afrique du Nord fut l'une des plus
grosses erreurs d'Hitler certes cela
fait mal aux os méditerranéennes pour
six mois avec un impact négatif sur le
ravitaillement allié mais cela mille les
troupes allemandes dans une situation
intenable d'où il n'y avait comme un
Stalingrad aucune retraite possible
la campagne du rat de novembre 1942 à
mai 1943 et s'acheva par une défaite
totale et la reddition des forces de
l'Axe avec 275 000 hommes fait
prisonniers
frenchoutenberg ne fut pas présent pour
témoigner de ce triste jour de l'armée
allemande
le 7 avril sa voiture sauta sur une mine
il perdit son œil gauche sa main droite
et deux doigts de sa main gauche en plus
de quelques autres blessures moins
graves
il fut rapatriés à Munich on craignait
qu'il ne perde totalement la vue
elle a mis été à l'aide de ces trois
doigts restants il écrivite au général
oldricht qui l'espérait pouvoir
reprendre le service actif dans les
trois mois
il avait dit à sa femme Nina je sens que
je dois faire quelque chose pour sauver
l'Allemagne
c'était le général holbridge qui avait
mis au point l'Opération Valkyrie avec
l'idée de créer un plan officiellement
pour faire face au désordre civils mais
surtout qui pourrait être mise en œuvre
lorsqu'ils clair serait assassiné son
dégoût de l'extrême droite le ramenait
au jour du putsch de la brasserie auquel
il s'était résolument opposé
contrairement à beaucoup de ses
collègues
ces craintes concernant les nazis
s'intensifièrent après la nuit des longs
couteaux où il les contrecara activement
en confiant à certaines de leurs cibles
des tâches politiques ou militaires sous
la protection de la Wehrmacht
il était le chef du bureau général des
armées et secondaire Friedrich from
l'officier que les comploteurs n'avaient
pas mis dans la confidence mais sur
lequel il se reposerait pour mettre en
œuvre l'opération Valkyrie le moment
venu
lui et fanfresco nourrissait d'autres
dessins connus sous le nom de code
opération Flash
en février 1943 alors que fansta
offenberg partait pour la Tunisie Paul
bricht décida que le temps était venu de
tester l'opération Flash
il ne pouvait pas se servir de bons
allemandes dont le détonateur faisait un
léger sifflement il gardèrent donc une
bombe anglaise que la RAF avait largué
pour des saboteurs
après un certain nombre de faux départ
il fut finalement convenu que le Führer
visiterait le quartier général du
groupement centre asmolenzk le 13 mars
à la dernière minute phone Tresco
suggéra à son chef voncloud d'utiliser
une unité de cavalerie pour éliminer
Hitler et son escort à leur arrivée
le commandant de la cavalerie le
lieutenant-colonal Beuze la guerre n'y
était pas opposé mais phone cloud
continuait d'hésiter
les comploteurs se rabâtir alors sur
l'opération Flash
la décision fut prise de placer une
bombe dans l'avion du Führer et de la
faire exploser sur le vol de retour ce
qui apparaîtrait comme un accident tout
à fait crédible
les conspirateurs continuaient en fait
de craindre que l'élimination d'Hitler
ne débouche sur une guerre civile autant
avec les troupes loyalistes qui
prendraient à partie les troupes
rebelles qu'avec la Wehrmacht affrontant
les SS
en dépit de cette crainte il avait été
un moment envisagé de l'assassiner aux
messe des officiers mais cette idée
avait été abandonnée en raison du trop
grand nombre de généros amis qui
auraient permis avec lui
on confiage la Brender l'attache de
ferrer subrepticement dans l'avion du
Führer des bombes dans un paquet censé
contenir deux bouteilles de brandy
il est remis au colonel hein un homme
qui allait jouer un rôle crucial dans
l'opération Valkyrie
on lui avait dit que le paquet venait de
phone Tresco qui expliqua que c'était un
cadeau pour son ami le général
elmoutchtif
c'était un autre sympathisant du
mouvement antique lyrien lui aussi avait
été dégoûté de ce qu'il avait vu en
Pologne mais manquait de courage dans
ses convictions
bien qu'il se fut porté un jour
personnellement volontaire pour
assassiner Hitler il sait ça plus tard
toute activité
juste avant de remettre le paquet à
Brandt alors qu'il embarquait dans
l'avion je l'abendorf pressa un petit
bouton qui devait briser une fiole
d'acide corrosif supposé rongé un câble
retenant un ressort qui une fois libéré
devait mettre à feu le détonateur
l'excitation des comploteurs se
transformant en déception quand un
message radio annonça non pas le crash
de l'avion d'Hitler mais son arrivée
effective au repère du loup Rastenburg
en Prusse orientale
non seulement il avait survécu un autre
complot mais brand se promenait avec un
paquet qui risquait d'être découvert
comme étant une bombe
phone Tresco prit rapidement son
téléphone pour avertir Brandt que de
mauvaises bouteilles avaient été
envoyées
le présent aurait dû contenir des
spiritueux d'une bien meilleure qualité
cela brendorf s'envola le lendemain pour
le quartier général d'Hitler où il
échangea la bombe contre deux vraies
bouteilles de brandy
en inspectant plus tard la bombe il fut
établi que le ressort avait bien percuté
le détonateur mais que ce dernier avait
subi une défaillance à l'allumage Hitler
devait la vie à l'air plus froide de la
Carlin de la viande
une seconde tentative devait être lancée
huit jours plus tard le 21 mars cette
fois sous la forme d'une mission suicide
par le chef du renseignement du
groupement centre le colonel frayeur
phone Gersdorf
Hitler devait participer aux cérémonies
de la journée des héros aux agao sa
Berlin
encore une fois le froid allait jouer un
rôle
bien que les bombes fournies par phone
Tresco
USD daytonateurs
de mettre deux fois plus de temps à
exploser
le colonel devait pouvoir s'approcher
suffisamment d'Hitler sans attirer
l'attention pour être sûr de réussir
mais Hitler ne resta que 8 minutes
cette tactique consistant à écourter ses
apparitions paya une nouvelle fois
l'arrestation d'un agent de l'adver à
l'automne 1942 alerte timeler sur la
duplicité d'un certain nombre de
personnels clés du service de
renseignement militaire et le 5 avril le
second de l'amiral Canaris le colonel
Hans Oster fut assigné à résidence
il fit également arrêté le pasteur
protestant Dietrich bonheur lui qui
avait protesté contre le traitement
infligé aux Juifs et avait fourni des
fonds à des réseaux clandestins et dans
les Juifs à s'échapper
il avait des contacts rapprochés avec
l'ABS vers qui lui avait fourni les faux
documents nécessaires pour remplir ses
missions
Himmler avait son propre plan pour
dissoudre la verre et il y réussi en
février 1944
son rôle sera repris par le rhsa
l'office de sécurité centrale qui
travaillait pour ses SS tandis que
l'abbert servait la Wehrmacht
ministre de l'Intérieur et chef des SS
kimmler en savait probablement plus sur
les conspirations contre Hitler qui ne
voulaient bien le montrer et était prêt
à profiter des événements dans son
propre intérêt
il fut contacté à l'été 1943 par
johannespopits prussien des finances et
membre du groupe de l'ancien maire de
Leipzig l'un des leaders de la
conspiration berlinoise
il approchait Himmler avec l'intention
de le convaincre de rejoindre un groupe
qui renverserait le Führer et
négocierait la paix avec les puissances
occidentales
bien qui me l'air est refusé la
proposition il ne mentionna pas la
rencontre secrète qui venait d'avoir
lieu plus encore en juin 1944 il fit
savoir l'amiral Canaris alors en
disgrâce qu'il était au courant d'une
conspiration en mentionnant en
particulier les noms de bec et girl de
leur
était-ce une menace ou un avertissement
cela reste flou mais on peut présumer
qu'il savait que l'amiral transmettrai
l'information
début 1943 le général Steve qui avait
été le destinataire supposé des
bouteilles de brandy explosives et
kimmler avait surnommé le petit lutin
empoisonné avait prévu de placer une
bombe au sein du quartier général
d'Hitler mais décida finalement
d'annuler son plan
son stock secret de bombe explosa à
l'intérieur de l'enceinte du quartier
général et ce fut uniquement parce que
l'officier de l'adver qui mena l'enquête
faisait lui-même partie de la
conspiration que les membres du complot
ne furent pas découverts
en novembre le capitaine d'infanterie
axelfun dem Bush devait réaliser le
modèle d'un nouveau par-dessus militaire
conçu par Hitler et que ce dernier
devait approuver cette fois la bombe
devait exploser alors que le Führer son
œuvre
bouche devait alors le ceinturer et le
tenir jusqu'à ce que la bombe explose
deux jours avant la date prévue un
bombardement allié détruisit le stock
des prototypes
peu après bouche fut sérieusement
blessée et fut remplacé par Heinrich
voncle le fils de l'un des plus anciens
conspirateurs
une nouvelle inspection fut programmée
pour le 11 février 1944 mais Hitler ne
va pas
un autre essai allait être tenté le 26
décembre 1943 à wolstein
un jeune officier fut envoyé par le
général holbridge l'initiateur de
l'opération Valkyrie pour faire un
rapport aux commandes suprême sur les
changements dans l'arme la réunion fut
annulée
dans la valise du visiteur parmi ses
feuilles de notes fut placé une bombe il
s'était entraîné à déclencher la bombe
avec trois doigts et une paire de pinces
ce jeune officier n'était autre que
fontsta offenberg
à Blender strasseux le dynamisme que je
t'a offenberg apporta à la résistance
berlinoise fut quelque peu atténuée par
le fait que le plus ancien des officiers
impliqués dans leur plan le général Beck
se remettait d'une sérieuse opération
due à un cancer et que phone Beach Leben
également sous traitement médical avait
été relevé de son commandement
les espoirs des conspirateurs étaient
maintenant focalisés sur un homme dont
la valeur militaire inspirait le respect
non seulement de la Wehrmacht mais des
armées du monde entier
en janvier 1944 juste après la première
tentative de funsta offenberg remet les
était devenu le chef du groupe B sur le
front de l'Ouest l'armée qui devait
attendre et repousser le débarquement
allié
forcez de se retirer l'Afrique du Nord
romane avait été affecté en France où il
allait être mis en contact avec deux
vieux camarades qui l'intégreraient au
Cercle des conspirateurs
le premier était Alexander fun
Falkenhausen gouverneur militaire de
Belgique qui fut arrêté après la guerre
et condamné à 12 ans de travaux forcés
pour crime de guerre
durant son temps de commandement
28900 juifs et 43 000 non juifs avaient
été déportés dans les camps allemands
sa condamnation fut annulée trois
semaines plus tard grâce à des témoins
dont le héros belge d'origine chinoise
CAN soulling qui témoignait qu'il avait
sauvé la vie de beaucoup d'autres
en fait il avait été appelé à Berlin
pour expliquer son comportement
Carl gordler et le maréchal fun witts
Leben était ses amis et il partait avec
eux la haine du national socialiste
le second était Karl frencht Nagel le
gouverneur militaire de la France
militant d'extrême droite durant les
premières années éclairiennes il fut
impliqué dans le premier complot contre
Hitler lors de la crise tchécoslovaque
il avait fait ses preuves comme
excellent acticien lors de l'opération
Barbarossa où sa 17e armée remporta deux
batailles majeures mais ceci est la
promotion qui avait suivi n'avait pas
entamé son opposition résolue à la
direction que prenait l'Allemagne
l'intermédiaire entre ces hommes et
romaine fut un vieil ami de ce dernier
le docteur karlstrolin
lui et garde l'heure hurle à témérité
d'adresser une lettre au ministère de
l'Intérieur d'himler en août 1943
dans laquelle il lui demandait de cesser
la persécution des juifs et des églises
chrétiennes de restaurer les droits
civiques et un système judiciaire
indépendant du parti nazi des SS et de
la Gestapo
remèdent été convaincus édite astroline
il est de mon devoir de venir au secours
de l'Allemagne
il fut l'un de ceux qui craignaient de
sanctifier Hitler en assassinant et qui
voulait l'amener devant un tribunal où
il serait jugé pour crime contre
l'humanité dont le peuple allemand
lui-même
comme nous l'avons vu tous les
conspirateurs n'approuvaient pas ces
méthodes
phone rouge tête l'officier supérieur de
Rommel et commandant des forces de
l'Ouest fut alerté personnellement par
Romel de ses intentions et lui exprima
alors sa sympathie
mais lorsqu'il lui proposa de les
rejoindre il lui répondit
vous êtes jeune vous connaissez et vous
aimez le peuple vous le ferez
garde l'heure fit un grand nombre de
tentatives pour approcher les Alliés
recherchant leur soutien pour un nouveau
gouvernement allemand
mais la réponse concernant les
conditions des alliés restaient
invariablement la même la reddition pure
et simple
du côté de l'est certains espérait une
réponse plus positive de la Russie mais
de telles espoirs durent être abandonnés
lorsqu'il devint clair que les Russes
s'en tiendraient également au terme de
la conférence de Casablanca une
reddition inconditionnelle
ils étaient donc seuls
en janvier 1944 le mois où Romel fut
appelé en France le cercle chrysao de
phone moteur qui s'était consacré aux
discussions de sujets telles que le
système judiciaire poste nazi fut
démantelé et ses principaux membres
arrêtés
phone Walker dit à sa femme d'aller se
cacher sans lui dire où elle se
trouverait de façon à ce qu'il ne puisse
révéler sa cachette même sous la torture
à ce moment l'opération Walkyrie entrait
dans sa phase finale
staffenberg insistait pour que le timing
soit parfait
la police de Berlin soutenait
l'opération car son chef von elle dorth
était lui-même l'un des conspirateurs
à ce moment-là il y avait à Berlin de
nombreux personnels des SS et de la
luftwafe en bien plus grand nombre que
ceux de la Wehrmacht
même une fois Hitler mort il fallait
s'attendre à ce que ses troupes
résistent et s'opposent à toute
tentative de renverser le régime
dans les deux premières heures le
quartier général des communications
nationales le central téléphonique et le
télégraphe la Chancellerie les
ministères et le quartier général de la
Gestapo devait tous être sécurisés
le repère du loup devait également être
coupé de tout contact avec le monde
extérieur
tout devait être terminé avant que
l'annonce de l'opération Walkyrie soit
lancée sur les ondes par phone wits
Leben le nouveau commandant en chef de
la Wehrmacht Beck le nouveau chef de
l'État et guerre de l'Eure le nouveau
chancelier
les alliés les barquières sur les plages
le 6 juin 1944 alors que staffenberg ne
s'attendait pas à une tentative pour cet
été
à cause du mauvais temps la luftwafe
avait été incapable d'exécuter ses
missions de reconnaissance habituelle et
remèdes avait fait un rapport disant que
le débarquement n'était pas imminent
seul Hitler avait pensé que la Normandie
pouvait être le point central d'une
invasion mais pour une fois il n'avait
pas imposé ses opinions
le gros de l'armée allemande se trouvait
dans le nord de la France au-dessus de
la Seine
romaine était rentré en Allemagne méfie
demi-tour en apprenant la nouvelle
Hitler avait demandé à ne pas être
dérangé et lorsqu'il se réveilla
finalement ordonna simplement que tout
soit remis en ordre avant la nuit
le chef de guerre réussite à rencontrer
romelle et son commandant phone
roundstett en France le 29 juin les deux
lui demandant de faire la paix avant que
l'armée ne soit réduite à néant
cela ne servit à rien
Hitler en était arrivé à la conclusion
que les débarquements étaient un simple
feu de braise la guerre serait gagnée
grâce à une nouvelle arme miraculeuse le
V1
lorsqu'il devint clair que le
débarquement de Normandie était un
succès garde-leur et bec commencèrent à
se demander si leur complot même en cas
de succès servirait encore à quelque
chose
pour fun PRESCO l'araignée qui avait
tissé sa toile pour capturer le Führer
cet assassinat devenait plus symbolique
que concrètement utile
une tentative devait être faite pour
purifier l'âme de l'Allemagne
l'assassinat doit être tenté à tout prix
même s'il ne devait pas réussir une
tentative pour prendre le pouvoir à
Berlin doit être exécuté ce qui importe
maintenant n'est plus l'aspect pratique
il s'agit de montrer au monde et à
l'histoire que les gens de la résistance
auront eu le courage de passer à l'acte
comparé à cet objectif rien n'est
important
avec ce soutien de phone Tresco
staffenberg retourne avoir Hitler le 11
juillet avec sa valise piégée
la nuit précédente les conspirateurs
avaient décidé de tuer également Himmler
et going mais Himmler ne va pas et
lorsque je taffenberg téléphona à
olbrischt pour annoncer qu'il pouvait
encore tuer Hitler et going il fut
ordonné d'attendre afin de pouvoir
assassiner les trois
à son retour la nuit qui suivit il
rencontra albridge Québec pour les
pressés de passer à l'action la fois
suivante qui me l'air et gering soit
présent ou non ils approuvèrent
le 15 juillet je taoffenberg retourna au
repaire du loup et les conspirateurs
étaient ici certains de leur réussite
qu'il décidèrent de lancer l'opération
Valkyrie deux heures avant le
rendez-vous avec Hitler
de retour à Berlin à 11h le général
oldricht donna les ordres de Valkyrie 1
et les troupes semirent en marche pour
occuper le centre de villamstrasse
arriva à la salle de conférence fit son
rapport et se retira pour informer
allbrish que tout était en ordre et
qu'il allait retourner en réunion et
armée la bombe
revenu en salle de réunion il s'aperçut
qu'Hitler avait coupé court et quitté
les lieux
il avertit albridge de ce nouvel échec
revint à Berlin ou guerre de leur
argumentait à nouveau en faveur de la
solution occidentale une paix avec
l'Ouest laissant les forces de l'Axe
continuer leur lutte contre les
Soviétiques
bec ne voulait pas en entendre parler il
ne croyait pas qu'une paix séparée
puisse être négociée mais comme albricht
il pensait que le complot contre Hitler
devait être mené à bien ne serait-ce que
pour sauver l'honneur de l'Allemagne
olbrischt avait tout juste réussi à
sauver sa peau persuadant kitle le chef
des forces armées et from son propre
supérieur que l'ordre donné aux troupes
n'avait été qu'un simple exercice
le même jour ils apprirent que le
général phone Falkenhausen avait été
relevé de son poste de gouverneur
militaire de la Belgique et du Nord de
la France
deux jours plus tard le véhicule de
commandement de Romel fut touché par un
chasseur en rase-motte et on pensait
qu'il n'avait pas survécu
les conspirateurs avaient perdu ceux qui
le décrivent comme un pilier de leur
puissance
le jour suivant l'heure de l'heure
entendu qu'il me l'air avait donné
l'ordre de la rareté
le soir du 19 juillet staffenberg
travaillait sur son rapport à la Bender
strasseux ayant été appelés pour briefer
Hitler sur les dernières informations
concernant les remplacements sur le
front de l'Est
avec une bombe fournie par le général
STIF qui avait adapté l'une des bombes
de la RF la veille pour être certain
qu'elle exploserait bien au bout de 10
minutes
Stauffenberg prit la route une dernière
fois pour le repaire du loup le 20
juillet
après le petit déjeuner il retrouva le
chef des transmissions de l'okavé comme
prévu le général felgible
du Führer en coupant toutes les
communications radio téléphoniques et
télégraphiques
le général kitele patron de l'okavé l'un
format alors que le rendez-vous avait
été avancé à 12h30
comme il était déjà midi il ne lui
restait que peu de temps pour se
préparer
dans l'antichambre je taofenberg brise à
la capsule contenant l'acide
la bombe était armée
à cause de ces difficultés à manipuler
les pinces cela lui prie plus de temps
que prévu et lorsqu'il rejoint kaiton
celui-ci était furieux ils étaient en
retard
lorsqu'ils entèrent dans le bâtiment il
expliqua au sergent chargé des
téléphones qu'il attendait un appel
urgent en s'assurant bien que kitle
entendait sa demande
une fois dans la pièce il nota que les
fenêtres étaient ouvertes ce qui allait
réduire l'effet de souffle
un perturbable il s'assurera que la
bombe serait juste à côté d'Hitler qui
était assis au centre de la table de
réunion un meuble inhabituel qui était
soutenu par deux gros blocs plutôt que
par quatre pieds
il y avait en tout 23 officiers présents
pendant quitter étudier la carte étalée
devant lui
l'un d'entre eux était le colonel hein
l'officier qui avait sans le savoir
transporter la bombe cachée dans deux
bouteilles de brandy
il ne prête à guère attention lorsque le
nouvel arrivant posa l'attaché-case à
quelques centimètres du chef suprême
puis je t'ai offenberg quitta la pièce
avec le faux coup de téléphone comme
excuse sans que personne ne le remarque
c'est peu après que le colonel brand Hut
un geste qui change à l'histoire il
voulut mieux voir la carte et son pied
heurte à la malette il l'a pris et la
posa de l'autre côté du large support de
la table en bois
cela allait avoir pour conséquence
d'atténuer l'effet de la bombe mais lui
n'allait pas être épargné
Hitler arrivait à la fin de sa réunion
lorsque kaitel remarqua que stephenberg
n'était pas revenu il se précipita hors
de la salle et à 12h42 la bombe explose
vit le bâtiment en flamme avec les corps
projetés en l'air et fut persuadé que
personne n'avait survécu
avec sang-froid il se fraya un chemin à
travers les trois postes de contrôle
successifs laissant le soin à son aide
de camp et Co-conspirateur le lieutenant
Afton de démonter la deuxième bombe et
dans jeter les pièces dans les
broussailles pendant qu'il roulait à
toute vitesse en direction de l'aéroport
son avion n'avait pas de radio mais
lorsqu'il appela oldricht à
l'atterrissage il fut abasourdi sur la
benne de leur strasseux les ordres de
Valkyrie avaient été retirés du coffre
de bridge mais ni le général Beck ni fun
Witz Leben n'était arrivé pour en
prendre connaissance
Paul bridge lui-même n'avait peut-être
pas oublié le fiasco qui était arrivé la
dernière fois qu'il les avait lu en
conséquence de quoi aucun des plans
prévus pour sécuriser Berlin n'avait été
mis en œuvre
quand je taffenberg arrive à Paul bricht
redoubla d'activités
par le général from à son insu
convoqué par ce dernier et afin de
convaincre from de s'engager il lui
demanda d'appeler le repère du loup
espérant recevoir la confirmation de
l'amordi-claire
il fut très surpris d'être aussitôt mis
en relation avec kaitl le chef des
armées qui est censé avoir péri dans
l'explosion
mais le pire était à venir Hitler avait
survécu
quatre officiers avait été tués dont le
colonel Brandt et 5 blessés
mais Hitler était en si bonne santé à
quelques blessures mineures près qu'il
déclara à Mussolini venu le voir dans
leur suivant l'explosion qu'il est
évident que rien ne peut m'arriver il le
fait aucun doute que mon destin est de
continuer dans cette voie et de mener
mes tâches à bien ce qui est arrivé
aujourd'hui en est le point d'orgue
ces clipsant discrètement old bridge te
se réunit avec staoufenberg Québec
était sûr que kaittel bluffait
mais dans l'hypothèse où ce ne fut pas
le cas il tomba d'accord avec le chef
d'état-major le complot devait se
poursuivre
en conséquence de quoi staffenberg
téléphona au quartier général de French
stupenager à Paris
toujours décidé et énergique le général
passe à l'action
le soir même les 1200 SS et leurs
officiers présents dans la capitale
française était écroués
olbrischt revint ensuite avec
staoufenberg au bureau de from où il
tentèrent une dernière fois de
convaincre le chef de la réserve quitter
était mort
le général semblait peser le pour et le
contre et oldricht finit par lui dire
que quel que soit la vérité il était
trop tard pour tergiverser
l'opération Walkyrie avait bel et bien
été lancée
c'est de l'insubordination automnale
générale qui demanda à ce que l'officier
qui avait donné l'ordre le colonel
funkerhim lui fut amené
tentant d'augmenter la pression sur from
staffenberg lui révéla que c'est
lui-même qui avait placé la bombe et
qu'il avait vu de ses yeux l'explosion
Trump lui répondit alors que la
tentative avait été échouée et que je
taoffenberg devait se tirer une balle
dans la tête séance tenante
lorsque je taffenberg refusa il menaça
de mettre tous les officiers en état
d'arrestation
Paul Brice répondit vous vous trompez
c'est nous qui vous mettons en état
d'arrestation
à la fin de la journée les conspirateurs
avaient pris le contrôle de Blender
strass mais de rien d'autre à Berlin et
les Panzer n’étaient pas arrivés
le général hockner brillant-chef de la
Panzer vaffeux qui avait été renvoyé par
Hitler était parmi les conspirateurs et
il était à présent à Blender strasseux
ce jour-là mais ces demandes semblaient
ne pas avoir été prise en compte
c'est à peine croyable mais c'est un
officier relativement jeune le major
rameur qui avait été confié la tâche
d'arrêter au Ministère de la Propagande
l'une des plus importantes figures du
Troisième Reich Joseph Goebbels
primer ne faisait pas partie du complot
mais il était prêt à remplir sa mission
trompé par l'annonce de la mort d'Hitler
gobels lui demanda alors s'il pouvait
reconnaître la voix du Führer et la
réponse est en affirmative et lui offrit
d'entrer en contact avec lui par
téléphone
Hitler lui ordonna d'écraser
l'insurrection et de n'obéir qu'aux
ordres de gobels et d'Himmler
rémer retira par conséquence et troubles
de la villamstrasse et décida d'occuper
la commande en tour à Hunter Linden
envoyant des pelotons pour intercepter
les autres patrouilles qui parcouraient
la ville
à 6h30 du matin il fut annoncé qu'un
attentat pour assassiner Hitler avait
échoué
la nouvelle fut transmise à travers
toute l'Europe
à Prague et à Vienne les généraux qui se
préparaient à arrêter les SS et la
Gestapo commencèrent à hésiter
à 8h20 il me l'a annonça que kaitl avait
été nommé chef de l'armée de
remplacement et que seuls ses ordres
devaient être suivis
l'échec de la prise des chaînes de radio
eu des conséquences désastreuses
lorsque Witz Leben finit par arriver il
passa à bec et asta offenberg un savon
pour leur échec sur toute la fête bien
qu'il n'est pas lui-même pris la peine
d'être présent pour superviser les
opérations il partit très en colère
à 21h il fut annoncé que le général fun
Haze qui avait ordonné au major Raymer
maintenant promu colonel d'arrêter
gobels avait lui-même été arrêté
puis vers 10h30 un groupe d'officiers
armés servant sous les ordres dolbyricht
qui était devenu de plus en plus
suspicieux à propos de ceux qui se
passaient sur la benne de l'orchras pour
demander des explications à leur
officier supérieur
un grand nombre de coups de feu furent
tirés et staffenberg fut touché au bras
avant que les conspirateurs ne soient
maîtrisés
ils furent conduit dans le bureau de
from où il retrouvèrent celui qui avait
été leur prisonnier et ce dernier leur
ordonna de rendre leurs armes
mec demanda à être dispensé de cet ordre
en tant qu' ancien supérieur de from
comprenant sa requête celui-ci lui dit
simplement de s'assurer que son revolver
était bien pointé sur lui-même c'est ce
qu'il fit et il appuya sur la détente
mais la balle ne fit effleurer sa tête
il demanda alors à effectuer une seconde
tentative qui échoua elle aussi from
ordonna un officier aidé ce vieil homme
il fut alors traîné hors de la pièce et
on lui tira une balle dans la nuque
ukner lui déclina l'offre de suicide
from se tourna vers staffenberg son aide
de camp à heften allbricht et Metz un
colonel de l'état-major général et bien
messieurs êtes-vous prêts demanda-t-il
les quatre officiers furent conduits
dans la cour et abattu instantanément à
la lueur des phares d'une voiture de
commandement le rôle exact de from dans
cette affaire reste flou on ne sait
toujours pas si la simplement voulu
préserver l'honneur de l'armée par une
action si rapide ou si l'espérait plutôt
couvrir ses arrières si c'était la
seconde hypothèse il se trompait
à une heure du matin le Führer fit un
discours retransmis à la nation
annonçant qu'il s'agissait d'un crime
sans précédent dans l'histoire de
l'Allemagne
il déclara qu'il allait en finir avec
les usurpateurs un gang de criminel qui
seront éliminés sans merci et que nous
traiterons de la manière à laquelle nous
national socialiste sommes habitués
il dit très clairement ce qu'il voulait
pas de tribunaux militaire pour eux nous
les traînerons devant la Cour populaire
pas de longs discours pour eux la cour
agira à la vitesse de l'éclair et deux
heures après que la sentence ait été
décidée
par pendaison sans pitié
la Cour populaire avait été établie en
dehors de tout cadre légal et avec
compétences pour un grand nombre de
soi-disant crimes politiques qui pouvait
inclure les grèves le commerce illégal
et le défaitisme
elle était présidée par Roland priceler
qui servait à la fois le procureur de
juge et de jury
lors de la Grande Guerre il avait été
enfermé dans un camp de prisonniers de
guerre en Russie et de nombreux nazis
pensaient qu'il était à l'heure devenu
un bolchevik
ce stigmate devait lui rester et
l'empêcher d'atteindre des postes plus
élevés malgré ses fervendes convictions
nazis et ses jugements sans pitié
lorsque phone Fitz Leben apparu devant
lui sales et pas rasé sans ces fausses
dents ni une ceinture pour son pantalon
son juge lui hurla et toi sale vieillard
pourquoi tripotes-tu ton pantalon
phone witch Leben devait être l'un des 8
premiers à être jugés devant la Cour
populaire
comparaissez avec lui phone ASE qui
avait donné l'ordre d'arrêter Himmler
Steve qui avait été le destinataire de
la bombe avec les bouteilles de brandy
et le général opner le chef des Panzer
avec eux se trouvait quatre jeunes
officiers subalternes qui avaient
travaillé avec sta offenberg dont l'un
de ses cousins York van bourg
le 8 août il furent pendu comme du
bétail comme Hitler l'avait ordonné
à la prison de plotsensi ou temps de
résistant allemand furent exécutés ils
furent isolés pour un châtiment
exemplaire être pendu à une corde de
piano attaché à un crochet de boucher
la scène fut filmée pour le bon plaisir
d'Hitler
le général from fut arrêté par himler
qui était devenu le nouveau chef de
l'armée de remplacement
il fut juger devant la Cour populaire
pour l'acheter peut-être du fait de
l'ambiguïté de son implication dans le
complot il évita la pondeaison et fut
fusillé pas un peloton d'exécution
garde-leur avait pris la fuite avant le
20 juillet ayant été avertis que la
Gestapo avait lancé un mandat d'arrêt
contre lui
Hitler mis sa tête a pris pour un
million de marques et il fut repéré par
une connaissance féminine qui avait
rejoint la Luftwaffe
il fut arrêté et bien que jugé par la
Cour populaire en septembre il ne fut
exécutée qu'en février suivant de même
que phonepopits le ministre prussien des
finances
on pense que tous deux ont été épargnés
durant quelques temps par Himmler qui
espérait s'en servir dans les
négociations avec les alliés lorsqu'il
devint clair que de telles transactions
n'auraient pas lieu leur surf fut scellé
sur le front de l'Est le Major Général
henningfun PRESCO se tourna vers son
aide de camp schlabrendorf et lui dit
nous avons fait ce qu'il fallait hitler
n'est pas seulement l'ennemi de
l'Allemagne mais aussi du monde entier
il ajouta que dans quelques heures il se
tiendrait devant Dieu et qu'il pourrait
répondre de lui-même en toute conscience
ce matin du 21 juillet il prit la route
pour une destination sans retour
dégoupilla une grenade à main et ce fit
sauter la tête
ma gueule qui avait ordonné la détention
des SS à Paris et choix dans sa
tentative de convaincre le maréchal
vonclugger de le soutenir
en regrettant l'échec du complot dont il
niait avoir eu connaissance il
conseillage toute ma gueule de se
changer en civil et de fuir
rappelez pour rendre compte de ses actes
il s'arrêta à Verdun la grande ville
forteresse et tenta de se suicider mais
ne réussit qu'à perdre la vue
on dit qu'il entra dans un délire dans
lequel il hurlait sans cesse le nom de
rebelle
tu t'amener sur une civière devant
Roland price
à la mort dans la prison de plozzency
Clauger se suicida lorsqu'on lui demanda
pourquoi il avait été injoignable durant
ce fameux jour il était certain qu'il
allait être impliqué
le second de stupe ma gueule le colonel
of hacker sida sous la torture et
impliqua romaine
ce dernier ne se faisait aucune illusion
sur ce qu'il attendait il avait déclaré
à son ancien chef d'état-major le
général spydle maintenant arrêté
quittent l'air était devenu complètement
fou il donne libre cours à son sadisme
sur les conspirateurs du 20 juillet
rebelle ne pouvait pas s'y opposer ayant
eu de graves fractures au crâne à la
tempe et aux mâchoires ainsi que des
blessures à l'oeil gauche
Kittle le chef des armées se rendit chez
lui avec deux aides dont l'un apportait
du poison
il lui dit que si l'acceptait de prendre
ce poison il échapperait à la Cour
populaire sa famille ne serait pas
inquiétée et il aurait des funérailles
nationales
il accepta près de son fils qu'il
mourrait dans le quart d'heure à venir
la version officielle le déclara mort
d'une embolie cérébrale
en tout plus de 7000 personnes en
liaison avec le complot du 20 juillet
furent arrêtés
4980 furent exécutés dont la moitié par
la Cour populaire parmi elles fonmolke
le fondateur du Cercle chrysao qui
déclara à l'intention du juge il est
donc ainsi prouvé que ce ne sont pas les
plans où les préparations mais bien
l'esprit lui-même qui doit être
persécuté
le frère de staoufenberg et le pasteur
Dietrich bonhofer faisait également
partie des condamnés
seul un homme réussit à échapper à la
corde et se fiche la prunorf
la chance était toujours du côté de
l'homme qui avait tu les nerfs assez
solides pour placer une bombe dans
l'avion du Führer et aller la rechercher
le lendemain
alors qu'il allait passer devant la Cour
populaire le 3 février une bombe
américaine tu as sur le coup le juge
fricler tout en détruisant les dossiers
concernant shlagrandorf et la plupart
des autres survivants
après avoir été transféré vers plusieurs
camps de concentration successifs il fut
finalement libéré par les troupes
américaines et devint juges après la
guerre au sein des cours
constitutionnels de l'Allemagne de
l'Ouest
beaucoup d'autres joueurs un rôle dans
la Résistance à Hitler et ce qu'il
représente certains par de petites
actions en refusant de faire certaines
choses mineures d'autres en abritant ou
en aidant ceux qui étaient victimes de
persécution d'autres encore par des
actes de sabotage
les protestations massives des membres
de l'Église romaine catholique forcer
Hitler a renoncer à sa politique envers
les personnes handicapées mentalement ou
physiquement
ceux qui ont enfin les ordres du Reich
l'ont fait en risquant leur vie
que de considérer ce complot comme un
actisolé mieux vaut le considérer dans
la continuité de la lutte de l'homme
contre l'oppression même lorsque les
chances sont contre lui
aucune de ces personnes n'a estimé
pouvoir se dédouaner en considérant
qu'il n'avait fait qu'obéir aux ordres
comme les crédits le Major Général
énigme
sont des lois pour les idiots